no other lingerie brand
could compete with victoria's secret
they could get the best talent in the
world do you believe you believe let's
go
every celebrity wanted to be part of
that show
[Applause]
it's a 7.5 billion dollar business this
company is crushing it
everybody knows what the victorious
secret brand means wexner always claimed
that victoria's secret was a ladies
paradise and had nothing to do with men
it's tits and glitch
[Music]
a lot of people have heard of victoria's
secret but very few people have heard of
the billionaire behind les wexner les is
a genius his brand dominated the malls
of america he is the guy who figured out
how to make american shop shop shop shop
but there was something else going on at
victoria's secret
there's a number of red flags and so
many questions and there was talk
there were rumors
billionaires are all secretive but
wexner is one of the most it begs the
question why
and there's this huge mystery people had
mentioned this name
and part of the mystery
was jeffrey epstein oh boy
this is trouble
the notion that epstein would turn up
around victoria's secret is not
surprising
but what wexner did was unthinkable
giving him power of attorney
there wasn't a part of wexner's empire
that epstein didn't have access to 20
companies 19 trusts real estate the
million-dollar question is why a
gentleman as brilliant as wexner could
allow this guy into his life wexner
claims that he had no idea that any of
this was going on it just makes you ask
who's telling the truth it was a perfect
storm of problems and it's much bigger
than epstein
victoria's secret lost connection with
the customer things were falling apart
business is feeling what's going on here
there's a larger picture to all of this
the politicians the royalty intelligence
agencies why was epstein doing this was
this about power and blackmail and makes
you wonder how many more layers there
are to this world
this is all a story that was meant to be
hidden and stay hidden
and we were never supposed to see any of
it